president Trump will return to Texas
tomorrow to visit Houston and other
areas hit hard by Harvey the president
was criticized after his first trip for
not visiting victims in the storm
ravaged areas Vice President Mike Pence
did meet with victims when he went to
Texas yesterday he cleared storm debris
at a home in Rockport and viewed the
damage from a military aircraft major
garrett is at the White House
major good morning good morning as is so
often the case with this presidency
President Trump and vice-president pence
were a study in contrast in their trips
to Texas responding to hurricane Harvey
mr. Trump was cheered but kept his
distance from suffering and devastation
while his vice president did exactly the
opposite President Trump sent us here to
say we are with you vice president
Penn's toward a heavily damaged
neighborhood in Rockport and consoled
residents at a church gutted by
hurricane Harvey we will be here every
day until this city in this state and
this region rebuild bigger unlike
President Trump the Vice President
hugged the afflicted posed with
volunteers and cleared branches from a
front yard of the Naro family who wept
while they watched it's a long way to go
it's not months but it's years president
Trump's trip to Corpus Christi and
Austin was far less intimate critics
said mr. Trump failed to meet with
victims mention the loss of life or see
devastation up close and the modern era
presidents are graded on compassion Bill
Clinton tended to shine in moments of
tragedy george w bush faulted for his
initial distance from hurricane katrina
later got up close and embraced the
victims and president obama drew praise
even from republicans for his prompt
response in New Jersey to superstorm
sandy the Vice President made a point of
saying mr. Trump would be returning to
Texas on Saturday president Trump often
reminds us that we are one American
family that when one hurts we all hurt
Sarah Huckabee Sanders White House press
secretary said the president will donate
1 million dollars to her
pain relief efforts whether that comes
from his foundation or business account
Sanders could not say the president
already donates his presidential salary
to other charities Gill 1 million dollar
donation will be greatly appreciated
thank you very much major